اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من الجليل الاعلى
اهلا بكم اشتباكات ضاريه في مدينه غزه
شمالي القطاع وخان يونس جنوبا وكتائب
القسام تقول انها اوقعت اليات اسرائيليه
في كمين مركب واستهدفت دبابتين غرب خان
يونس كما قصفت بالاشتراك مع سرايا القدس
تجمعا لقوات متوغل غرب مدينه غزه في حين
قالت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الجيش لا
يزال بعيدا عن القضاء على القدره
الصاروخيه
لحماس مع اتساع نطاق الخلافه بين واشنطن
وتل ابيب وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه تقول ان
اداره بايدن تضغط على نتنياهو للموافقه
على هدنه لاربعه اشهر نتنياهو يقر بوجود
خلافات مع واشنطن ومصدر قيادي في حماس
يقول ان الحركه في المرحله النهائيه من
المشاورات الداخليه ومع فصائل المقاومه
بشان مقترح تبادل الاسرى وان انها سترد
عليه قريبا عشرات الشهداء في قصف اسرائيلي
لمناطق في خان يونس كما واصلت قناصه جيش
الاحتلال استهداف المواطنين والنازحين في
مراكز الايواء داخل المدينه زوارق حربيه
اسرائيليه قصفت شاحنه مساعدات امميه كانت
متجهه الى مدينه غزه في حين قال الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني ان قوات الاحتلال اطلقت
النار على مباني الجمعيه ومستشفى الامل في
خان يونس قو الاحتلال تطلق النار على
فلسطيني قرب مستوطنه معل ادوميم شرقي
القدس بذري محاوله تنفيذ عمليه طعن وتقتحم
مناطق عده في الضفه الغربيه وتشن حمله
اعتقالات من جانبها قالت منظمه العفو
الدوليه ان القوات الاسرائيليه اطلقت في
الاشهر الماضيه موجه عنف عاتيه ضد
الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه باستخدام
القوه المميته دون
مبرر الى
اللقاء